good afternoon thank you so much for
coming along I hope you're enjoying the
first day of NDC London unless you've
been at the workshop beforehand in which
case is your third day of NDC London out
of interest how many people here are
here at their first-ever NDC London
event Wow most of you okay that's great
well welcome it's my third year of doing
this particular conference I work I do
anything common to the wave of the world
so it's quite nice not half as far to
come for this one so I'm gonna be
talking today about sort of the
interplay really of architecture and
organisation and specifically looking at
how micro services and sort of go hand
in hand with the the way we're thinking
about IT organizations so there's some
stuff here if you're not take micro
services but if you are interested in
Microsoft X
there's gonna be a lot here for you to
think about in terms of how you
structure your work and how you get
people organized around things it turns
out there's a little awful lot of is a
huge extent to which this you know you
can see micro services as purely a a
technical architecture but it really
comes into its own I think when you
align that with an organizational
structure that supports this way of
working as to try to trying to sort of
shoehorn micro services into existing
organizational structures may not give
you the outcomes you want I'm not going
to try and convince you that micro
services are good or bad it's more that
if you're gonna do them he was some
other things you should be thinking
about from an organizational point of
view so my name is Sammy man I wrote a
book a while ago on micro services I'm
in the process of rewriting this book it
came out in 2015 a few things have
changed I I now have to just have to
rewrite the second edition there and put
the word kubernetes on every fifth word
otherwise it just doesn't sell I've also
just got a new book just was released at
the end of last year called monolith to
micro services that's a book which is
sort of a was the first book was like a
broad swathe looking at all the impacts
of software development and how micro
services are impacted so looking at
testing and deployment and sort of
architecture and organizational
structures this book is very much a deep
dive which is trying to help guide
organizations that want to take an
existing system and migrate to a micro
service architecture i think which i
think is a situation that many people
are in so if you want to know the sheer
horror associated with braking Franchi
would constraints in databases this is
the book for you amongst other things so
it is available in the shops now but
we're gonna talk about micro services
and here's how I always do micro
services I draw them as hexagons I like
hexagons it'd be kind kind of come of a
thing for me it's a nice shape and we
CEO BC architects like this is a logical
architecture and when we're talking
about what makes micro services
interesting maybe from a technical or
behavioral point of view the thing we
sort of reiterate over and over again is
this idea of independent deployability
and often the you get the an
architecture like Microsoft architecture
is really optimized allow around
allowing you to make changes easily so
what we get aiming for with the micros
architecture is the ability for you to
take make a change to one service in
that architecture and deploy that
service into a production environment
without having to change anything else
where there's a lot of other noise we
can talk about microsoft architectures
we can talk about kubernetes and docker
and go and function as a service and
Kafka and all of this lovely stuff which
you may or may not want to use with a
micro service architecture but above all
it's an architecture which is designed
and sort of is very opinionated about
this idea of allowing services to be
changed and deployed independently of
having to change or deploy anything else
in your system that's it
that's really it the whole purpose of
that now of course that's very easy to
say it's much harder to do and so an
awful lot the detail is how do we come
up with architectures that work in that
way we also talk about them being
modeled around parts of the business
domain this is actually one of the key
ingredients to helping around in
dependability that's something we can
explore a little bit in this talk but
often what we focus on the technical
aspects of mycosis architecture there's
a lot of what I've done in the past
often sometimes the organizational stuff
isn't talked about enough and that's
what I'm trying to fit
in the talk today so here we are I've
got my micros architecture I want to
work on something I only get something
done I wouldn't be able to change that
service and deploy a brand new version
that shipping service into production
without having to change anything else
that's it that's it
because it's very easy to do in a slide
right that's as easy as an animation but
we can see it again if you want I don't
think is going to help and you know
there's a lot of technical detail in
terms how we do this we talk for example
about not showing databases and we'll
talk about why that is and that can make
these types of things more difficult
anyway hold that thought so let's look
at other types of system decomposition
so with a micro service architecture a
micro services are an opinionated style
of service-oriented architecture they
are a type of service-oriented
architecture but as a certain type of
service-oriented architecture that has
some fairly strong opinions about how
things should be done and one of those
opinions is this idea of independent
deployability another one of those
opinions is that we should decompose our
application into services that are
structured around parts of our business
domain well why is that even relevant
which picking ideas arbitrarily out of
the year well maybe but what they bear
with me so there's I've got a different
type of system decomposition and one
that might be familiar to many of you
we'll look at maybe or some people
called layered or horizontal styles of
decomposition so I've been using a sort
of example of a fake domain for a while
this is music Corp music Corp sell
compact discs online you can understand
how long I've been using that example
for because it sells compact discs
online and I haven't worked out what to
replace it with yet but we'll get there
we might start setting vinyl because
then it would be at least a bit more
relevant and we've got our application
it's a standard standards of a very
simple web comic ecommerce application
running online web-based system and we
made a decision to split this monolithic
application into two parts when I talk
about our model if I primarily talk
about a monolith as a unit of deployment
different styles of monolith so here we
can imagine this is all the code is
packaged together on a single process
with a single datastore underneath it
which is kind of a classic view of a
monolithic system although there are
other models out there and we've made a
decision that we're going to break this
into two pieces
we said we were to scale it we've heard
about microservices and we want some of
that service goodness and we're gonna
break it apart so we can do more because
we wouldn't be like Netflix or Spotify
for some reason and we look at exact our
existing code base and we say well
actually I'm sorry testing code base
there's a nice API here it's a nice
clean API why don't we just make that
service API and so we do something like
this we crack open our application it's
likely take a a hatchet but this API
that used to be something that called
inside a process boundary it's now a
services boundary and a classic place of
format kind of decomposition is maybe
around your persistence layer so here
what we've done is now we've got a music
court service that renders up our HTML
pages to the outside world known as
single page app nonsense we're
old-fashioned I mean I say we're setting
compact discs online we clearly haven't
learned so we're serving up HTML pages
to the outside world and on the back end
we've got our persistence service and
that is allowing for the retrieval of
Speight that we store so information
about your customer the orders the items
that we've got for sale and obviously
manages state saving data and that data
needs to change it manages our whole
kind of durable persistence of data but
basically it's a wrapper around a
database right that's what this is and
of course we've done quite sensible
actually which is we have one team that
looks after the exam usik court website
and we have a different team that looks
after the persistence layer and actually
you know I think having ownership of
teams likeliest makes sense if you have
a service having that so it's owned by a
team in general is the right model and
we're going to talk about why later on
so you know it's ok but we have issues
here so how many people here release
software at least once a month into
production ok
how have you really software maybe once
a week or more into production Wow okay
that's a lot of says probably about are
they about five to ten to the room temp
center room maybe fifteen to the room in
step ins a lot we want to ship software
quickly and what we often find
especially where you work with
organizations that have actually had IT
systems for a long time is the
architecture of those applications don't
always a lend themselves to the fast
pace of delivery that we now expect from
our systems and often we look back on
architectural styles that made perfect
sense when we were leasing software
every six months every 12 months every
18 months and now they're not
necessarily ads fit for purpose in the
current age and that's often the case
with architectures like this let me
posit a simple example we're going to
give our customers of Music Corp the
ability to select their favorite genre
of music it's a very simple idea that
goes your profile page you click on the
drop-down box and you say my favorite
genre of music is click death polka
which is a mash-up of death metal and
polka music
I don't know I'm telling you obviously
all know this so I selected death polka
is my favorite type of music and making
that change is a very simple operation
is one field now for that to work with
this architecture to make the changes in
my system required for that I'm going to
have to expose from that persistence
layer some information about what the
genre options are in my music Corp
service that I'm gonna have to construct
some sort of drop-down combo box with
all the entries in that combo box when I
select my favorite genre I'm then going
to have to save that information and
that will call back into the Pistons
less so a very simple change in
functionality I've added one field and
I'm now going to have to make that
change in two different places
moreover I'm gonna have to coordinate
that change across two separate teams so
I'm going to have to somehow work out
the right order in which the sequence
this work and I'm either gonna have to
chew decide to deploy both of those
changes together as a single deployment
which makes it makes for a lockstep
release or otherwise I'm gonna maybe
have to release the back end persistence
layer first and then the front end music
core player or some other sort of
combination of that now you're a tech
conference right you're here learning
about amazing technology
thinking about your skills and how to
grow what do you think about all the
amazing things you're going to do with
and knowledge you-you-you gain from this
to this these this a few days but let me
break it to you
75% of what you do in your career is
going to be taking something out of a
database and putting it on a screen and
if you're very lucky the other 25% of
your career is taking something from the
screen and putting it back in a database
right that's most of what we do and the
rest is kind of just how we make that
efficient but in this sort of type these
types of layered architectures like this
this isn't an efficient operation we're
having to make changes in lots of places
to make simple things like that happen
now I would say at that point what
you've got is a system that you know
that is showing low levels of cohesion
of business functionality I'm having to
go to multiple parts of my system to
make a change which points to a low
degree of cohesion I mean the concepts
of cohesion as we tend to use it in
terms of source code actually come from
the early days of structure programming
back in the mid 60's and early 1970s
back when we were talking about how to
design systems which make a sort of
modeled around modules perotta programs
were getting bigger and more complicated
we needed ways of breaking those
programs up and modules what we were
talked about so that was all about how
can we create refined good module
boundaries as these terms are talked
about cohesion the code that's that
changes together should stay together I
don't have to go to five different
modules to change some piece of
functionality I want to reduce the
number of modules that I have to change
in order to churn make the change happen
and service bound is no different to
module boundaries in that regard so here
we have simple load architecture often
has this issue of low cohesion in many
ways this architecture is optimized
around us just making changes of
database layer or just making changes to
the UI layer how many of your features
really would that apply to something
else we'll learn for the days of
structured programming is a thing called
constant times law and so constantine's
law states that as your cohesion reduces
your coupling increases and it makes
sense coupling is the property where I
have to change one thing I all have to
change something else if my
functionality spread
all of those layers I'm gonna have to
change lots of layers together to make
that change happen so as we as we reduce
our cohesion we increase our coupling
that sounds like not great if what we
now expect of our architectures is the
ability to be able to make changes and
deploy them quickly so the other thing
this is a bad architecture I'm just
saying that these styles of
architectures tend to not necessarily
live up to what we want out of them
given that our business conditions and
our expectations of our customers have
changed and this is a very simple
example of a layered architecture this
is a much more fine-grained snapshot of
a system I worked on many years ago this
was for a ticketing company based here
in Europe they had about 60 services and
they had a very slow pace of change and
I got chatting to an independent
contractors working there they've done
an excellent piece of work how many
people here are big fans of JIRA okay so
as how many people here are made to use
JIRA otherwise they don't get paid yes
right okay there's some great stuff you
can do it tools like JIRA I mean you
could probably also do a TFS but you're
probably you know anyway don't go there
so one of the things you could do is
when you make a commit you can associate
that commit with a piece of work that
working like a story that you're working
on so you could put little like the
number of the story and you would come
up that linkage and this contractor had
basically worked out that for every
story that was completed on average for
each story that was completed by this by
this team they would change six services
so on average one story would impact six
different services and they were
basically their 40 developer pairs doing
two-week sprints each developer pair
would on average complete at least one
story per sprint so that's 40 stories
each of those stories changing at least
six services that basically meant that
every single sprint every single service
had well in all likelihood had to be
changed in some way shape or form so now
what you've got is what's called a
distributed monolith where everything is
so cross-cutting that everything has to
be changed together and deploy together
how much fun is it doing a lockstep
deployment of a massively distributed
system sounds like great doesn't it
a lot of fun and actually is a good tip
if you're looking at your own
microservice decompositional efforts
keeping an eye on how often a story cuts
across multiple service boundaries is a
good idea we can't eliminate that with
micro services we want to reduce that
possibility or reduce the frequency of
that you can also use source code tools
like code scene to look at change couple
detection seeing when different parts of
systems seem to change in lockstep with
each other that can often point to fact
that the service boundaries are in the
wrong place so I refer to sort of
heavily layered architectures as onion
architectures because they have loads
and loads of layers and when I slice
through them they make me cry so now
these of course are kind of specific
examples of a more common form of
layered architecture and a very kind of
very familiar one to many of you and
that would be the classical three-tiered
architecture presentation business data
access part of the reason we see this
architecture so much I'm convinced is
because it is universal I can do a
conference talk about the three-tier
architecture and at no point do I have
to engage at all with a real problem I
don't have to talk about the problem
you're facing or the problem that you're
facing you're building a nuclear power
station oh great well what you want is
your presentation your business your
data access your building an e-commerce
site where you want your presentation
your business your data access is
universal I can turn up any client in
the world I can get out my ink stamp
with my architecture snap it onto a nice
a3 sheet then I'll laminate it and say
that's the architecture you want right
presentation or the front end logic is
in the presentation layer and there was
no business logic in the presentation
layer is there because that would make
it quite easy to create a decent UI so
we'll keep it all out so that makes our
life harder all the business logic is in
the business layer definitely there's no
behavior in the data access layer
because the relationships between data
and our relational databases don't
represent business concepts do they only
they do and we don't we definitely are
not going to put stored procedures in
our database but we do so we lie even
about what these layers are are for and
of course you know that's it's great
it's universal everyone can do it I bet
you if you go back on Monday I spent at
least half of the audience here if you
go and open your code bases and you open
your source code you'll find package
structures aligned around these ideas
presentation business data access
presentation business data
says this has become our primary way of
finding module boundaries and finding
service bound user name space boundaries
and package boundaries in our code base
and if you read anything around
structure programming from 1960s and
1970s we're all insane but we do it
because there's another reason why we do
this so much and that's not just because
it's universal it's actually down to how
traditionally IT organizations have been
managed and grouped together because
what do we have we have the front-end
developers who work on the presentation
layer we know who the front-end
developers are don't we because they've
got the funky haircuts and the tattoos
and all the piercings and they know with
a good coffee shop certainly right those
weird fixed wheel bikes and talk about
JavaScript all day and then we've got
the business developers the business
developers we own the business services
there are lots of hardback books by
Martin Fowler and talk about message
brokers and any service bus and talk
about application integration patterns
and Kafka right and they think that all
the logic is there and there's no logic
anywhere else they look down their noses
at the front-end developers because
they're not real develop full-stack and
then we've got the DBAs we don't know
where the DBAs are but the database
seems to be working but we haven't heard
from them from a while and this is the
prop I mean they look that this is
speaks to the sort of sometimes
poisonous tribalism exists within our
organizational structures I'm these are
stereotypes but we have stereotypes for
people in a camp different from us this
is how we were traditionally organized
in IT you are put in a team with other
people with the same core competency as
you you are in a team with other Java
developers if you're a Java developer if
you're dotnet developer unity mad net
developers if you're an X motif
developer which I was and none of you
know that is you and a team with other X
motif developers right and that your
groups based on your core competency and
this is based fundamentally on
manufacturing theory called Taylorism
and the idea here is if I know all the
Java developers are there I can make
sure they're all busy I can optimize my
organizational structure for utilization
if not all if some of my developers
aren't doing Java development I fire
them right so they thought everyone make
sure they're doing some Java development
everyone keeps busy right and optimizing
for utilization turns out to not at all
be the same thing as optimizing for
throughput which is what we learn
shift from sort of tailor its views of
manufacturing moving into lean
manufacturing sometimes the idea is to
focus on delivery rather than focus on
being busy so this is our traditional
organizational structures this is how we
set up and it aligns to the
architectures that we've come up with
by organizing people around their core
technical competency we've ended up with
architectures which are driven by
technology all of our database related
functionalities in the data access layer
all of our front-end logic is in the
present the front-end presentation
layers that's where those specialists
live and these things become
self-fulfilling this actually you know
and then of course we had the problem
that we have all these people we have
the other silos don't we we have the QAS
that live by themselves and we had the
operations people who lived by
themselves and then they would report up
into their structures and then you'd
report up the CIO and the CTO and then
you'd have the yawning chasm of distrust
to the business and the business is
always in air quotes and sometimes it
doesn't apply to an organized-crime
family it's like we talk about these as
being separate worlds and this is very
old-fashioned now because we've moved
away from this haven't we we've realised
that to be a proper technology business
you the business makes money through
technology we want closer working
relationships so we're breaking these
silos down and we're also starting to
break these silos down as well right
getting people working closer together
having more poly skilled teams but our
architectures often stop that from
happening our organizational structures
are driving our architecture and this is
not a new observation going all the way
back again to the 1960s 1968 to be exact
when Conway's law was coined melvin
conway made the observation which
organizations which design systems are
constrained to produce designs which are
copies of the communication structures
of these organizations so how we've
organized ourselves drives our system
architecture and this is there's been a
bunch of studies that have looked into
this one of the best ones actually was a
paper that was a bunch of research and
at Microsoft where they were looking
into sort of the kind of different
metrics around and maybe their
correlation of different metrics and
correlate
with failure rates in the Windows Vista
codebase and the Windows Vista codebase
had a lot of failures to go around so
and they found that social metrics were
heavily interacted with those things
they they could see the impact of social
groupings so stronger forms of ownership
led to better error rates it's a bunch
of great research out there that leads
to all these sorts of observations and
this I've always found to be true right
the organization ends up driving the
architecture so if you categorize people
based on their core technical skill you
end up with an architecture driven by
that core technical skill so we try and
fight against this and some of you may
have heard of the term called the future
based team I so rather than having
handoffs whatever avoid handoffs right
because if I have to ask the
presentation team to do something and
then but they can't do that until the
business layer team have done something
and they can't do that until the DBAs
have done something we're constantly
having to handoff and coordinate between
people but lean manufacturing 101 is the
way you optimize for through pose is
avoiding handoffs I might go and ask you
to do something you say well that piece
of work something it take me a week and
I say great that's fine and you say I'll
get to it in six months because got
other things on right now that's what
happens when we have multiple teams
trying to coordinate with each other so
feature based teams are a way to try and
solve this what you do is you get
together a collection of individuals who
and in that team you have the skill sets
required to make all the changes to
deliver a feature so a team owns the
end-to-end delivery of a piece of
functionality as it'll be a piece of
user-facing functionality so you might
have within that team someone that can
do some database work you have some say
services developers and some front-end
developers this whole full stack
developer stuff is rubbish right as
charity majors says you're not a full
stack developer unless you design the
chips we don't need full stack
developers what we need a full stack
teams the idea that one person can be a
brilliant front-end developer and a
brilliant services developer and a great
database administrator and a great
operations person may be one of those
people exist so maybe I'll get to meet
them one day but we're looking at here
our poly skilled teams people who want
their ok being flexible and where they
work kind the interesting thing is you
look into it if you're a Java developer
and you're
Java developer sometimes the right thing
to do is not write some Java code it
might be to help out in some Albert area
of the of the development process to get
a feature out of the door so you get a
close working relationship those people
who might work on different parts of
stuck historically are much more now
aligned about delivering a piece of
functionality to the customer they can
work closely together you're avoiding
the handoffs because you're working in
the same team and now they can make the
changes in all the layers and all the
places that need those changes to be
made the problem though is when you
start trying to apply these
cross-cutting feature based teams on top
of an architecture which then isn't
aligned around that if you end up with
all the sources of contention because
guess what I'm trying to make these
changes and get my feature out but I'm
probably not the only feature based team
all fighting in the same area like I
want to get my change out but I can't
because other teams doing a refactoring
in that layer and they want me to wait
every fracturing is done and oh no
there's yet a third team that says hang
on a minute you can't deploy anything
this week because we've got to roll out
a database change so when you get
multiple teams all trying to work on the
same piece of code and all trying to
work and coordinate around releasing the
same artifacts you get all these
horrible sources of contention and that
can be even more complicated if you
still have teams working at right angles
to you so the feature based team isn't
inherently a bad idea but the idea of
owning end-to-end the delivery of a
piece of functionality to a customer
having a poly skilled team that can
avoid handoffs those are great ideas the
problem is sometimes these layered
architectures don't allow those great
teams to work effectively and in my
experience it tends to be the
organization that wins but the
organization wins very very slowly right
so this is where you get all these
sources of contention and infighting
fundamentally we've got multiple teams
all scrapping it out in the same area
and they're having to coordinate the
changes they're making coordinated
deployments that we want to make so it's
a nice idea these end-to-end slices we
like the idea of having end-to-end every
piece of functionality so with
micro-services what we say is well
rather than decomposing our system
around technical lines with these
end-to-end sort of holies of these
horizontal slices instead we make
end-to-end slices our unit of decomp
if we wanna own pieces of functionality
will own those piece of functionality
end to end STIs end to end slices here
they become our service boundaries so
within each service we take those
end-to-end slices and we peel those off
and say that is actually a service
boundary and inside that service
boundary we might have maybe we have
those three layers of presentation data
access business layers as you start
peeling these things apart sometimes
some things don't need databases
sometimes I don't need front ends but
the idea now is when I'm working in a
team and a team owns a service that's a
poly skilled team owning a piece of
functionality business functionality
we're optimizing our architecture around
these business domains to increase the
chance that we do changes they're gonna
sit within those service boundaries like
well I want stories to not have to cut
across loads of different teams and lies
across the service ownership so as I'm
making changes I want those to be as
easy as possible to get out into
production function that's what micro
service is all about really I think Neil
Ford once said that micro services are
the first post DevOps architecture which
I think it's kind of right in a way but
I would argue that even more influential
has been continuous delivery I can say
that because that's what influenced me
to come to work on all this stuff the
idea of getting software out of the door
quickly and effectively and safely right
these ideas that came from continuous
delivery which is treating every
check-in as a release candidate getting
that software out as quickly as possible
reducing your batch sizes evidence has
shown that those organizations which
release software more quickly also have
morph more frequently also have
significantly lower failure rates they
tend also to have companies where the
developers are happier and the
businesses perform better all right
we've got data on this now we know
continuous delivery as a concept works
what we're now looking at our
architectures that may continue to
livery easier to do and that's what
micro services are really about this
idea of independent deployability
finally get a change out easily I want
to be able to make a change and deploy
that service in isolation it reduces the
risk of each deployment we then start
talking
his ownership models I've always sort of
kind of come in and said well actually
this idea that a team should own a
service it's not all the only model that
people look at though so in the rest of
talk I want to look at some different
options around owning services and what
that might mean for your organization's
nice in front of wrote a piece a while
ago con code ownership and so he
introduced these terms kind of strong
code ownership weak and collective code
ownership now it's worth pointing out
that when Martin was talking about his
ideas he was talking about modules and
code not necessary services so he talked
about sort of strong ownership of a sort
of a piece of code basically means these
people can change this code and nobody
else can if anybody else wants a changes
code they have to come and ask the
owners of a piece of code so within an
organization there might be part of your
code base which is owned by a small set
of individuals and those are the people
who are all responsible so that's for
that piece of code but they also vet any
changes that anybody else makes and they
affected the acts as gatekeepers around
that piece of code we saw that weak
ownership which I don't think really
ever exists in weak ownership you can
commit into other people's code but
you're expected to check in with someone
before you do it and ask is that okay
I find weak ownership do very rarely
exist by the other end of the spectrum
we have collective ownership anybody can
change anything and that's an often an
idea that is put out there by certain
people and for some situations it works
well but not situations it can be quite
disastrous anybody can change anything
so everybody's in charge of everything
it has some real nice benefits though so
here I've got three teams and I've got a
bunch of services and I say well I'm
allowing anybody to change any one of
these services that gives you a degree
of flexibility around how you work
there's a lot of changes need to be done
in how we're doing shipping well we can
have more people storming around that
area of the code you get it makes it
easier to rotate people around so that's
quite nicely get a lot more flexibility
in terms of where you assign people you
sort of view people in a way as being a
bit more fungible what you've done some
shipping work you can go do work over
there you can work over there you can
work over there you'll be
fine it'll be absolutely okay well the
kind of interesting challenges those
when you have this idea of collective
ownership that anybody can change
anything who's sort of responsible for
the technical vision of that piece of
the code or what represents a good
commit or which direction we want to go
in should we be doing this major
refactoring actually when a cleaners
code up who's thinking about those
things
if you skip from one part one system to
another and there's no real sense of
ownership from that point of view it's
very hard to make those things work
coming back to that Windows Vista study
I mentioned Microsoft found that there's
a very good correlation between
ownership sure and failure rates they
see in their own internal projects the
high the churn of owners the higher the
defect rates that kind of makes some
logical sense in a way because people
going in and making changes that
realizing the impact of those changes
the other issue here is being aligned to
parts of the business I talk beside a
that we're trying to break down the
silos between you know the business and
IT but here I'm stopping this idea what
I could work on any part of my technical
landscape but often you know you'll have
different product owners with different
parts of your organization but if the
developers are skipping all around it
they're not going to build up any domain
expertise and they don't really feel
aligned to the business it still feels a
bit more like we're just a pool of
developers being moved around and
fundamentally we still have the
coordination problem here anybody who'd
change any service so how am I sure
which services are being changed by
somebody else now I do think this is all
about scale I think for small teams I
think if you've got like 15 20 people
I actually think collective ownership is
all right I think of many of those
issues around a lack of ownership they
are really really a fine when you've got
10 15 20 people you can coordinate about
all of this stuff you can be on the same
page you can have a collective view with
15 or 20 people just about you started
getting much beyond that and it's very
hard to get agreement on things so I
think as your organization grows as you
have more teams as you have more
developers the concepts of collective
ownership inherently starts to break
down unless you have a lot more top-down
control and constraint
so collective code ownership often the
way we would deal with wanting some
understanding about how things are done
in Aramis the collective ownership is
you have lots of people saying this is
what a good commitment looks like this
is the changes you are allowed to make
you'd have a small number of individuals
that be setting out the architecture
that you have to work within for example
and that's sort of how you try and make
collective ownership work out scale and
effective what means is you take away
the concept of ownership for the people
and you centralize it so the other model
here is more of a strong ownership model
so here teams own services so these
services are owned by certain teams this
is my stuff this is ours we are
responsible for it and this model also
makes much more sense if you're looking
at moving towards a model where your
teams are also handling the deployment
and operational aspects of your services
because now your sphere of
responsibility extends into the
operational domain and I don't know
anybody that has sort of that full
operational ownership and does
collective ownership at scale those two
ideas don't really work together
so here I've got very clear lines when
if you I understand who owns the user
service I also understand who is
responsible and accountable for that
service I have an increased concept here
of autonomy I'm now can free up if I
want to the team's owning these services
to make whatever changes they like
because they are the win the ones that
live with those changes I'm not worried
about somebody else coming in and going
well hang on this is written in Python
and I'm a PHP developer well that's fine
because you know they don't work in that
area when you have collective ownership
you tend to standardize in your
languages you tend to standardize your
technology choices you standardize on
your technical idioms that you're using
because you know a person is going to
probably pop into your project and work
there for a few weeks before going off
again when you have stronger lines of
ownership you're actually free people up
to make more changes locally and
optimize locally when you optimize
locally you might end up with
inconsistency but that still might make
people more productive
it's also I think someone should get
back it's also much easier here to
become a line to parts of the business
and in fact often the way you'll drive
team boundaries is but identifying team
boundaries that align to existing
organizational business structures you
know the classic model now you see a
product oriented teams where a product
owner is embedded inside a technical
delivery team I work on this part of the
business domain I get to know my product
owner really well I become basically a
domain expert as well as being a
technical expert expert on this part of
the system and that makes you much more
effective as a developer there are some
challenges this model one of the issues
is about bottlenecks like what happens
if this team is really under the pump
there's loads of change need to get made
right now in the account system how
we're going to make that work if they're
the only team that can make changes
there another issue that can come up
here is if if services are owned by one
team what happens when that team goes
away what happens is that team no longer
exists anymore
things become can become orphaned you
know you don't realize it you've got
site running in production it's been
there for like five years you're not
sure what it does but you know when you
shut it down the system starts working
you can't find a source code right so we
have to talk about how we're gonna solve
that as well and there is also this
balance of global versus local
optimization if you give these teams
more autonomy they might make different
decisions than other teams is that a
problem how much autonomy do you allow
them now I think in general as I would
touch done I think the challenges we
outlined with collective ownership
they're fine at small scale when you've
got five ten fifteen developers they're
fine when you start getting with
multiple teams or you've got lots of
geographical distribution collective
ownership really really struggles you
start seeing all kinds of bad outcomes
in my experience but it exists a bit on
a spectrum we think about collective
ownership and strong ownership they kind
of extreme ends of the spectrum and you
can play around with where you want this
this balance to be if your own
organizations with collective ownership
you're going to find a lot as the
stronger need for global consistency
because anybody can change anything
you're not going to want a huge amount
of variation
you're going to want to keep your choice
is the same or similar you're probably
going to have to have more consistency
and you might have to have that
consistency enforced that might result
in you putting constraints in terms of
what people are allowed to do all the
new techniques or technologies that
they're allowed to introduce into the
organization and that's to try and make
collective ownership work if you want to
allow for local teams to make decisions
that are best for them stronger
ownership makes more sense this team
could come up with a very different
answer to this team but it works for
them they are more efficient they also
feel more empowered some of you may have
their band pink came up with sort of
these these sort of three pillars of
motivation for a force of employee and
staff and talks about autonomy mastery
and purpose they're sort of interesting
right because purpose is like what am I
doing here what's my what's the point of
being here and and you actually do want
an aligned purpose across your
organization that can speak to your
company culture autonomy if someone else
is telling you what to do I don't have
much autonomy right so organizations
where you have collective ownership and
theoretically everybody's in charge we
know that's not always the case and so
your autonomy can often suffer but if
you're free to make your own decisions a
bit more your time is gonna be better
that also opens up the possibility of
improving your skills mastery as well
because you're freer to try and you
learn and use new things now you don't
have to be either end of this extreme
but you just got to recognize that this
trade-off in this balance exists and
you've got to decide what makes sense
for you and your organization now when
it comes to micro services the micro
service architecture I mean I think we
talked about so far is just about
generic systems when we talk about micro
service architectures we're focusing on
this idea of independent deployability
we want to be able to make a change to a
service and deploy that service into
production without having to worry about
impacting or changing anybody else so
that means we're much care much more
about having loosely coupled
architectures and we want to reduce
coordination as much as possible all
organizations which have embraced and
get the most value out of micro services
to have much stronger concepts of
ownership and they tend to give teams
more autonomy I have very very rarely
seen collective ownership work I've
never seen collective ownership work of
scale I'm just going to say it will come
back to some of the things you're
thinking about like what about github in
a minute let's take a look at an
organization that has chosen for a
fairly extreme form of local
optimization and autonomy and that's
Amazon Amazon of the famous - Pizza team
whoo Amazon who ended up affected
creating their most profitable product
AWS was inspired partly by services they
provided their own teams to allow them
to work independently from each other
product development Amazon is extremely
isolated so you know those product
oriented teams do not talk to each other
very much they do not align much on how
their product strategy reinvent two
years ago Amazon released their managed
kubernetes host service eks it was a
least well kept secret in the cloud
world the same day the same keynote I
think they also announced there's their
revolutionary cloud service that allows
you to basically run a container and be
charged on a per second basis I say
revolution because it's only about nine
months after Microsoft launched the same
service so I've got pro second priced
containers that's built by one team I
think it's the Fargate team or Farscape
always goes to confused and manage
kubernetes which is about running
containers that was done by a different
team and the question was also can I run
per second price containers on on eks
and they go all no ever looked into that
not join up at all and even worse
example of this would be AWS lambda
launched in 2014 so lambda allows you to
run a piece of functionality based on
something happening amazon's first ever
product that they launched a Tobias has
looked first ever product was called sqs
a simple queue service 2006 a service
queue you can put an item on a queue and
you can react when that item is put in
the Q lambda launched in 2014 it took
until 2018
that you could put an item and SQS and
have a trigger at lambda function for
years so it looks nuts at one level but
that's by design
coordinating around a product strategy
slows you down the decision Amazon have
made is we want to optimize to reduce
coordination as much as possible
so that we can go fast and get product
out and you can't say it's not working
for them because they're far and away
the biggest public cloud provider and
it's not even close right now that
leaves have a disjointed product
strategy absolutely but they've made
that decision that's a trade off they've
made they've optimized around local
optimization you've got like five
different ways of doing the same thing
in Amazon in loads of places loads of
places there's a huge overlap works for
them though you might not want that in
your own organization you might want
something a bit more in the middle it's
a choice that you get to make but Amazon
fundamentally prioritizes for local
optimization in terms of how the teams
work in terms of how the Prok strategy
works and we see the benefits and the
downsides of that as customers of AWS so
coming back to that collective ownership
we talked about a few the challenges
that associated with these collective
ownership models we have bottlenecks we
have orphan services and we have local
optimization issues so bottlenecks how
do we solve bottlenecks I've got a
service that's got too much work to be
done
this team is totally overwhelmed the
work is piling up and they're becoming a
bottleneck for the rest of the system so
how can we solve this well one option is
we could move people
I could add a person to the team that's
going to be much harder if people are
using different programming languages
but if I've got the same programming
language moving people might be okay and
actually a lot of organizations that do
allow for high degrees of local autonomy
will still say we have a certain number
of languages that we support like
actually we mostly coding go we're
mostly code in C sharp or we mostly code
in node and if you would go outside of
that you have to have a conversation
outside of that you can do what you want
but that gives them some flexibility in
terms of recruitment in terms of moving
people around and also in terms of share
tooling and code
another example would be a pull request
a pull request based model is
fundamentally a strong ownership model
when you if you are doing internal open
source you are basically practicing a
strong ownership model you have people
or you have people who have commit
rights when you send a pull request to
that team not by me to me transitions
and say please can you take my change
you've got gatekeepers who are saying
that yes that cheap that change is
acceptable I'm going to accept that
change now it's a strong ownership model
right pour requests are a really
effective solution for that but if
you're going to try and use a pull
request on an internal inner source
based model inside your own organization
and if you don't make that work then
it's also got to be part of your team
responsibility to actually make it easy
for people to send your pour requests
you've got to dinner you've got to set
aside time to help work with those
people cinemas pull requests to make
sure the changes are made correctly
you've actually got to make sure you
make time to merge those changes in done
well it allows you to remove a lot of
these bottlenecks I seen it work
incredible organizations I've seen other
organizations who say are we do internal
open source and what they mean is I've
got github Enterprise right it's
actually a working practice thing and
again if you're on a team to send you a
poor request they've got to know how to
use your programming language there may
be still some degree of consistency that
you want across that system orphaned
services get a bit more problematic you
know over time the people will drift off
they leave the company they move on and
this captains are quite a lot with older
Mac service organisations and the
problem is we've created these services
that do one thing and do them well and
they often don't need to change very
much so they're out there running we
might not have note we're now may not
have had to do anything with them for
weeks or months sort of end and then we
realized oh hang on no one uses it
anymore so what we do here well the
first thing is knowing is happening I
chatted to Sarah Wells who's head of
sort of resiliency and operations for
the Financial Times and actually looking
at this problem at the moment and so for
where they've got services that don't
have a concrete assigned owner they're
basically operating the who touched it
last policy which is if you commit on it
last ish now yours which I quite like
idea right you were near it when it was
last working so you're now on the hook
for this which I think it's quite good
for people we that we attend especially
that makes sense if we're trying to move
to a strong ownership model that often
isn't makes the most sense another
answer here which is to say we'll just
take ownership often the reason you were
trying to find who owns the customer
service is because you need to do
something to it well then it's now yours
you take ownership for that you now own
that the service you now get the commit
rights it's now part of what you're
doing and the other model that can work
is as a model I called the roving
custodian and that's where you have
people that know how that service works
and no longer in a team together but
they're still in your organization and
they might be static all over the place
and you just go in find about and say
look I want to make a change can we pair
on this change and get it committed and
they still vet those changes again that
roving custodian model to work those
people may now be in other teams but
it's got to be recognised as part of
their job they're still looking after
this service as well
that roving custodian model doesn't tend
to work for services that have sort of
operational upkeep requirements but it
can work well for services that may be
run by separate operations team all for
things like shared code and shared
libraries and things like that
so a bunch of ideas there last point you
talked a little bit about this local
optimization versus global optimization
thing and and the thing we have to
realize is that these things are not
there's not one right answer for
everybody and it's a constant ongoing
balancing act that you're going to be
doing in terms of how much variation do
you allow from team to team to team
versus how much consistency do you want
so I've got a team here the shipping
team who decided they want to use
because they want to be web-scale we've
got this team here who wants to use
Oracle because they've already got a
real court and it seems to be working
fine and they operate the if it ain't
broke don't touch don't touch it kind of
philosophy that's fine right and then
we've got a team over here that is going
to build their system using Cassandra
because they think they're going to have
lots of rights because they our product
is quite poor and we're assuming and
lots of people are going to be returning
our stuff
right now you could go to each of
teens in his situation and talk to them
and understand what they're trying to
solve the problems they're facing their
skillsets and you can say you know what
each of those teams has made a
completely valid and sensible judgment
about what to do I can understand why
they shipping team wants I can
understand why the customer service team
wants Oracle I can understand one
returns team thinks Cassandra is a great
idea and each wise decisions makes
perfect sense just looked at in local
context but when you start looking
across the piece you go do we want to
maintain three different types of
databases do we want to build up the
skill sets required in our organization
to run those things effectively in a
production environment do I want to
manage three different sets of vendor
relationships do I want to worry about
three different sets of security
upgrades and things that I'm going to
keep on touch off or maybe it makes
sense at a global level to say can we
just pick one of these is there one
that's good enough it's not perfect for
everybody but if we have one it might be
fine maybe we say can anyone use
right maybe go send the customer so I
suppose we could move it's not that bad
right
sometimes standardizing across the piece
makes sense early on Netflix when they
obviously a kind of money moved lot of
their estate over to AWS and have made a
very early decision to standardize all
their main data storage onto Cassandra
and their argument was look we know it
scales really well we went one scale the
company so that was one of the big
drivers but they also accepted that it
wasn't perfect for everything but it was
good enough for virtually everything and
what they did was they said are you
gonna use Cassandra but we're gonna make
Cassandra amazingly easy to use they put
a lot of work into spinning up Cassandra
clusters managing them handing the
operational cycles around those things
as well because it allowed them to
optimize at a global level now I can't
say what the right answer is for any of
you but for you to make a decision about
do I want to worry more about local
optimization in this regard or global
optimization is regard you kind of need
to know what's going on how would I even
know that all these teams are doing
these different things
and this is one change I see certainly
with starter out with scale ups people
have grown quite quickly is that you
lose track of what's happening so how
would I even know that we've got three
different teams thinking about four even
databases if I have that knowledge I can
at least start to make a decision about
what we want to do as an organization
and sometimes what basically is what you
need here is we always need those
cross-cutting groups we need another
overlay on top of this with gone from
centralized competency based
organizational structures which don't
necessarily work we want fast throughput
but now we kind of do need somebody
looking CRO across the piece at certain
aspects of our technology but rather
than this being the main driving force
of our organization it's an overlay this
could be as simple as having like a
community of practice do you have a
place where all of your teams can come
together and chat about the issues
you're facing
you might even in some situations want
some more over governance in this area
this can be a much more collective
activity as a really simple example of
how I've done this before and a few
organizations is we would just get the
tech lead to meet those teams we'd catch
up every couple of weeks saying what's
going on and then would use that to
surface up these sorts of issues but if
you don't have something that cuts
across this and some ability to look
across all the services and what's going
on you're not actually going to be able
to make that balancing decision okay
we've had 15 different databases now
should we try and slim it down to five
right if you don't know you've got those
15 different databases out there you
can't make those judgment calls now I
think this can make people worry that oK
we've moved to micro services we've got
to change everything we're going to rip
the whole system apart and and we've got
to start again with our operation I
don't think that's the case I think if
you've gone from an environment where
you're building a monolithic system you
will tend to have a higher degree of
sort of global consistency across that
monolith you will often have more of a
concept of collective ownership as you
move to micro services you're likely
going to look at - moving toward
stronger ownership this service is owned
by this people these people and that
allows them to iterate more quickly and
own the end-to-end delivery of that
software and so probably over time
could be moving for more from a world
where everyone does things in exactly
the same way and you're going to start
inching your way maybe back towards a
world of of local optimization
fundamentally micro-services are in
architecture which optimizes for
autonomy they're an architecture which
allows your team to take on more
responsibility and that's one of the big
massive issue the massive selling points
of micro service architecture if you go
buy into micro services and say we're
going to buy into micro services but
we're going to make all decisions
essentially and everything has to be
done the same way you're missing a huge
part of the benefit they bring but still
paying all the costs right so I think
you need to be a bit more relaxed about
this this balance by the way between
local and global is not going to be
static it's going to change as your
organization changes and as you use
things it's up to you that when you
start this journey as to how much
autonomy you want there's no sense in
saying right with deep micro services
and now Bob you're carrying a pager
you're now doing 24/7 support and you've
got to manage our databases and it's
like people's heads are going to explode
a normally for company right as you
start pushing these responsibilities
into the team those teams are going to
need help to learn those new skills the
way this works is you take those
additional centralized functions the
DBAs the operations team maybe even the
QAS
but setting up security team are still
these centralized resources and you say
no no with those teams now have to
change their role those people are now
going to embed themselves in those teams
they're going to help transfer those
skills make it a help most teams become
more dare I say it
full-stack right and that's a but
it doesn't have to be done overnight but
it does need to be done consciously it
doesn't happen automatically you don't
get autonomy if you say let's do micro
services you have to think a little bit
about how you shift the ownership of
activities inside your organization this
is a constant balance that you're going
to be going on do I want to be globally
consistent everywhere do I want to do
local optimization and some
organizations are here right you hear
about mando who have their 800 services
and they have actually they have they'd
say via more towards collective they
also have again a very
very standardized development process in
a very standardized developer stack they
don't allow for a lot of variation
because people will have to be able to
move around
maybe that's right for you as well who
knows but you've got to make that
decision
I've got load more resources over my
website you can find information about
my book there's a video of this talk is
going to be available after as if you'll
share with your colleagues but talks for
lots of the other things I've vias are
lots of other talks I've done are
available online but thank you so much
your time we've got I think five minutes
for questions but no one's got any
questions for me so the question was
with a micro service architecture I'm
breaking things up into services so now
I've got the account service and a
shipping service and they've got to
interact how do you maintain sort of a
consistency or about what if the service
fails for me so the question is
basically what you do in services fail
this isn't really an issue of
consistency or anything else like this
it's more about what you your
expectations you are of any service you
call so if I call a service and I make
use of a service you need to have a
shared understanding from you the person
calling the service and from the person
providing that service about what your
expectations are in terms of their SLO s
service level objectives so what you
would do is as a team who owns a service
as you say well this is our service this
is how critical this services to the
people that use us because remember a
service only exists to be called right
so you can be thinking who calls my
service and what do they need so if you
own the shipping service and I'm calling
the ship
servus I would have expectations about
your uptime on your availability or how
much accessible downtime that you're
going to have now if you're not a
critical service you don't need to be up
once a week
guess what happy days for you I can't be
cross if you're only up once a week
because that's what we agreed but if
your service needs to be up it needs to
be up there's no two ways around that
the responsibility where the
responsibility lies for uptime is a bit
more up for grabs so some organizations
practice the idea that the team owns the
lifecycle that service end-to-end that
team also owns responsibility for it
running in production that model works
well for some in other organizations the
team that develops that service will
hand that over to a mobile centralized
operations department and then the
responsibility for that service being up
would shift to the operators who are
looking after a system but fundamentally
if you were going to talk to a service
you need to have some expectation it's
gonna be up and if you haven't had the
conversation about what you need you
need to have the conversation
so either you so in some organizations
I've worked they'll be like across the
board they'll have a basic SLO so you
can say well when you go to any service
here's what you can expect you can
expect that service will be up between
the hours of 8 a.m. and 7 p.m. and
anything outside of that set for grabs
but you'll get and you'll get office
support during those hours and then
there'll be variations on top of that so
if you don't you've got to work that out
yourselves and every organization's a
bit different in terms of how critical
different service is going to be a
question here
well there's sort of the systems and an
organizational structure I mean if we
were going going full Conway and you
wanna go full Conway if you can write so
I got one sort of maybe quite a division
and that division is like everyone owns
everything and then I've got a strong
ownership here so I've got services I
would try and be really clear alike in
terms of how that division talks to this
division so I would still be very
explicit in saying these are the
interaction points from your well to my
world so if the you know if the
collective to ownership people are
calling into services owned by the
strong ownership people I think this
model gets quite clear which end points
you use who owns those end points what
do you expect these are the teams you
need to talk to and actually internally
it gets easier I need to talk to that
team and that team and that team there
are people provide my services and I get
backs I've got strong ownership when
you're going it other way it becomes
quite messy but fundamentally if you're
calling services owned by the collective
ownership part of the world you've got
to be able to say not just so we talked
about there what is loz who owns those s
are those who do I talk to about what my
requirements are they can say they're
collective ownership all they want but
fundamentally then somebody has got to
come with you and say this is what we're
going to do is what we're gonna work
towards so into an extent if they want
to work internally in this sort of
hippie commune collective mindset with
their drum circle or whatever that's
great but they still have
responsibilities to the wider
organization and if they want to fulfill
that collectively that's fine but you
should still be out of a conversation
about what those responsibilities are
and also hold them to account when they
don't deliver you you may well find if
you start having that conversation with
them that collective ownership starts
becoming a lot less collective okay any
other questions a bit help me to see an
apologize
okay well thank you so much your time if
you want to email me my details are on
the internet and Twitter's often good
for answering questions because everyone
can see the answers there but thank you
very much and I hope you enjoy the rest
of the conference
[Applause]